I worked at urban search-and-rescue
years ago I worked on robot servants
entrance to and that's a challenge
because you're in a situation where this
rubble you don't necessarily have flat
floor anymore and people were sterilized
to go to those faces the person who
wrote the contestant entry for the fire
truck entry they knew their stuff they
talked about the problems at real
firefighters face and that excited me
this idea that you know we have
technology that can actually image a
fire at the other end of the business
end of the ladder and keep the
firefighters away from the business and
while you steer it to exactly the right
place we also have technologies for
proximity for detecting how far away the
tip of the ladder is from a window or
from a brick wall and so you can even
imagine one day going farther into the
future automatic means when you look at
a picture of the building the
firefighter clicks on screen somewhere
and the ladder souls and goes there and
stays there and does station-keeping
just the same way you might hover a
helicopter exactly in one spot so that
project to me was really exciting
because today's technology if you just
added to today's fire truck right away
gives you more functionality and it
doesn't even more safe way for the
firefighter